we'll do the Australia for but Papa
Berber box its burden a box that's right
honest trailer commentaries bird box
settle down wow that really did right
before we guys this is in an alternate
universe we would be here talking about
Lego Batman but then bird box happened
and we like the like the Millennials we
some kind of are we borderline are we
got distracted by the shiny new thing
and made a last-minute substitution will
do like a Batman sometime someday
someday if we learn it returns our calls
yes yes so we I just grab these on the
way in by the way um but I didn't have a
larger plane with them now I didn't yeah
bird box
it's a Netflix feature is somewhere
between between a real movie and a
b-movie it's definitely above the
happening but below a quiet place you
mean be movie or a b-movie
it's nobieman it's no b-movie conjugal
relations with a woman it's no b-movie
the prayer it's not it's not a b-movie
it's a b-movie yeah to be moving yeah I
feel like if it had to come out people
would have been like okay if they came
out in theaters yeah if like bird box
came out people you see we're about to
be like yeah yeah oh well I think this
would have been crushed like review wise
at least buy a quiet place if they were
both theatrical releases that close to
each other this has been a real Dante's
Peak volcano that's Sherwood yeah break
very - I didn't I didn't hate it I
didn't love it it was very kind of
middle-of-the-road
yeah it's the movie as I think we
discussed was very split in the sense
that we liked the the timeline that we
began in and we did not like where we
returned to because it was just so
generic and so like it's the beginning
of the end of the world what's going on
out there we gotta get in the house so
there's a jerk there's a criminal
there's a cop and there's someone
freaking out
a lady with training lady was training
and that's all we find out about her
should we let in this new person or not
like
we've dancers be always more my wife
saved you and she died for it yeah yeah
yeah but the memes the memes of this
film was what led me to even realize it
existed and persisted I mean I think
it's because you can watch it at home
yeah watch it at home everyone can watch
it at home simultaneously and then
someone would see a meme I think and
then they'd watch it because they saw
someone on Twitter talking about it and
then it exploded yeah it blew up yeah so
was it good it was fine I think is okay
it's fine
some people love it though some people
yeah there's a lot of people that love
this movie
apparently I read on Twitter huh I did
not yeah I liked it no there's a lot of
questions I did like Sandra Bullock's
performance yes she's great she kind of
holds it together and what's his what's
his day road yeah he's awesome yeah I
was like come on two roads is great
middling Malkovich you know he had a few
good Malkovich moments but really a
waste of a perfectly good mouth he
seemed to have been half it was a half
milk yeah he was half milking at 2% yeah
two percent what is the most full
Malkovich whole Mel performance you've
ever seen Oh what yeah what's what's
your favorite whole milk performance I
mean aside from being John Malkovich but
yeah he's actually been more Malkovich
in other movies yeah in the line of fire
that's a pretty big that's that's close
to whole milk yeah I'll have to get back
to you on that what's what's your
favorite full milk I've always seen
video of it but he did a production of
true West and randomly one night during
the middle of a monologue he just like
dropped to his hands and started doing
donkey kicks on stage that's that's my
favorite whole mouth I'll try to find it
burn after eating his whole mouth yeah
definitely that is one of my favorite
favorite underrated movie lines that's
just in my head all the time it's not a
quotable line but it's just when he's
doing a step exercises it's like I'm
bigger than ever reference it in this
trailer that is a heavenly thank you in
there yeah okay well let's watch I hope
it done signs a deal with like like an
almond milk
here's a set of alternative absolutely
[ __ ] milk just based on the book that
came out four years before a quiet place
I think that's just worth noting to the
people who say this is a ripoff of a
quiet place it's not it's the original
version of I don't have one sense and
I'm in a horror movie but Netflix saw
how well this did and said let's
fast-track that one let's do that also
people that said this is a quiet place
I don't know how movies work cuz they
have Sandra Bullock and make a movie in
less than six months
I feel like Netflix could get me a first
draft credits we're doing it it's the
same as the the honest trailers
cinemasins he/she situation we're going
are you ripping each other off cuz ur
stuff shows up at the same time yeah
yeah we just do them that morning Y will
be all together yeah exactly it's like
oh we were both super sons like they saw
they posted three hours before do you
think we do you think we wrote recorded
and edited a trailer in three hours I
wish we just did it like I have a lot
more free time that we could do that
like it's really strange with all the
big movie channels do the same movies
when they come out on video and people
are talking about it again yeah
weird right mother's life would be
really bad I mean it'd be like the worst
version of RiffTrax or like oh that's
interesting
yeah huh no wonder if that comes back
yeah imagine all of our jokes but spread
over two hours and that's what I was
yeah
four minutes worth of jokes half a two
and a half hours oh boy oh yeah anyways
my god based on the book that came out
four years before a quiet place Netflix
invites you to wonder what if a quiet
world was
all of us are making the end of the
world great again
bird home box Oh feast your eyes are the
scariest movie that sounds like a
monthly subscription to locale snack
food and experience a horror film told
along two different occasions where one
has nothing survival difference that
hornish the apocalypse where the other
is a cross between the happening and the
first act of every zombie movie
ourselves and you better believe that's
where you'll spend most of the runtime
weird cast we talked about this weird
cast and Sarah Paulson yeah yeah like a
minute in the beginning good he used as
much as I like Bullock couldn't use the
movie about her Sarah Paulson yeah if
you swapped roles just her riding around
blind on a horse yeah yeah horsing
around horses can the horses see the
creatures well the cannibal secret like
well clearly they can birds can at least
yeah but it does since them except they
often don't I was noticing it yes that
bird box does not come into play unless
the plot demands that yeah bird box come
into play that's true yeah yeah did the
birds yeah yeah no I would do like
wouldn't all the birds in the world be
going crazy at the same time we have we
just as much a menace as the monsters
yeah just be like nose-diving and we
didn't get any horse payoff true and it
really bothered me they were laying the
groundwork for a third act horse really
we're an equestrian like I'm obsessed
with horses we grew our parents were
Cowboys and and we got no horse pay off
we just got down shit's creek without a
paddle
yeah yeah which also didn't well we'll
get to that part later let's keep going
village order to patrol the streets make
sure everybody was safe
oh why couldn't Netflix put the
Bandersnatch tech in this one come on go
back to the river it's working Sandra
Bullock stars as a woman trying to
escape her horse
so at 3 o'clock I'm gonna go check out
an Arabian stud in Sausalito I can
cancel the appointment we miss a horse
it'd be great to be at worst she's a mom
will do anything to protect her kids
from physical harm but it's pretty chill
with emotional trauma when the
apocalypse driving around the world
protect others even though the film
punishes everyone who tries to be a good
person
and the jerks get off scot-free
so just real life in gotcha post this is
usually it I guess it subverts usual
like apocalypse Tom B movie rules of the
jerks who who are only out for
themselves always get their comeuppance
and they're devoured alive in a very
satisfying moment mm-hmm not so much in
this one no not really not really at all
like the two people who Machine Gun
Kelly and Machine Gun Kelly and and
training my opinion yet they they bone
down than they bone out yeah and they're
never heard from again I was expecting
this just like they drive away and then
you like see the car burst into flames
or something or they get to the thing in
their day I know there's no they got out
they got out as far as we're at Lee and
Malkovich got to redeems he redeemed
himself in that he like did something
good for somebody else and died but he
his whole ethos of the whole film is
like don't stick your neck out for
anyone else be an [ __ ] be selfish and
it was great again and again and again
he was right
consistently consistently and feel weird
yeah and then you know and I get that
that's like Sandra is supposed to be her
arc because she's supposed to like start
off selfish and then grow into being
like a mother of these two children but
like nothing that happened around her
would push her into doing that
everything that happen around her she's
only lived on a hill that one time yeah
yeah and then has to like bribe her kids
to walk back to point suddenly the
monsters were able to do like
pitch-perfect impersonations without
looking at them they were like in
I was a source Nader kid where she got
all that yarn like I said I guess is
that a thing that thinks she Clips under
her belt and this like leaves a little
path of there's a cutscene where they
went to a Michaels
I have yarn I have a ball of yarn it's
very taut so like you'd have to be able
to wind it back up there must be a
device I must have just missed the blood
device like a fishing reel maybe kind of
a fishing reel perhaps maybe you can get
like a thing for cavers at like a
sporting goods store then she lost it
there there's people that go into caves
for lunker's know cave rivers yeah okay
rivers death like in Siam exactly those
little things yeah
that's all tank and dozer could stay
together during the big orgy they're
tied together on each other Jesus keep
coming this is our B+ game today we're a
little tired can they call that wine
flow or you'll fall prey to unnamed
unseen monsters because these mysterious
beings will make it kill yourself by
showing you stuff from your past I think
unless you have a mental illness and
which case you become a crazed murderer
or a remarkably under control murderer
all right away these monsters can't or
won't go indoors even though they can
clearly move things or maybe they're
made of wind and I guess they're a
threat even when you can't see them
shouldn't be stuck with the original
design oh no my greatest fear the old
dancing man for the six vice commercials
[Music]
like yeah I said the monster rules got a
little let's talk about this a lot I got
a little fuzzy
I understand leaving it up to the
viewers imagination and not showing it
to them because whatever we can think of
is probably scarier than what they're
planning on showing which yes wrinkle
baby but but it's weird because people
were clearly seeing figures from their
past or something hearing because their
audio sometimes yeah who I guess would
then make a really compelling like the
Candide like argument for why suicide is
the right thing to do right now yeah
like why is it that hearing Sandra
Bullock's voice makes them put a gun
under his chin and pull the trans
unclear are they just that spooky I
guess I mean I know a lot of people were
like that was a mystery man that's the
great thing you never know why but I was
a little curious like I didn't need I
didn't need the monster sit pull up an
Apple crate and sit down and tell me
yeah the whole motivation but I was
curious I thought it was building up
towards like maybe some hint or some you
know obscure Christopher Nolan like clue
that I could perhaps into it and frankly
they are only speculating I guess and
you kind of put it together from context
clues in the movie but that the mentally
ill are immune but not immune
not immunity affects them or has turned
into murderers it affects it affects
them differently purposely or this one
was fun to me too because like you're
either Sandra Bullock or you're crazy
like they're okay this didn't end up in
a draft but one of the things I was
kicking around that really bothered me
is what hey if you have like an anxiety
disorder that's a mental illness yes are
you now just because being in public
with large groups of people really
bothers you or you now just like you got
was claustrophobic so afraid of heights
that's why he's uh he didn't kill
himself yeah well yeah like the guy that
they let in is like it just seemed like
when a movie establishes rules which is
like if you see it then your eyes go all
crazy and you're nuts and the way that
you know that somebody's not crazy is if
you look at them and see so but to bring
in somebody whose eyes aren't all crazy
and they're like oh okay it's fine but
then it's like oh but it's kind of there
but it's but no one but it hasn't for
anybody else in this way like you're
just cheating and bending the rules a
little bit just for convenience like
that for me like that part was the one
that bothered me the most like I don't
mind the rules you set up that's fine
but then when you sort of like go around
them to but they didn't do that the same
to anyone else because there's an easy
fix there too because you've seen a
crazy person already at that point
that's like I found a bird his eyes are
screwed up he has bird box eyes yeah so
just make that guy not have Burt bucks
eyes yeah and okay and then as a viewer
I'm like why didn't that guy have Burt
bucks eyes but he's crazy and it can see
yeah I don't know it's a simple tricky
tricky that was the one farther than me
that's like it seemed a bit too bad yeah
get him keep gone so if you're ready for
the second most talked about suicide
forest video of 2018 performance and a
zillion no it's because that we're way
more entertaining than the movie itself
prompting Netflix to ask viewers to stop
doing their own bird bucks challenges
because as we all know they hate it with
someone blind us something exceptional
yeah story always mind the bollocks
thank God protein powder survived the
apocalypse Cyrus the grass five years
later
welcome to my house help me keep these
ghouls
I don't wanna but offers gonna run out
thank you
traitors boy you have your dog boy and
the last layer up organ trade dysentery
every time for tonight or influenza or
something did he persevere in the face
of lost or did you quit you know I
didn't even get to call about it I
definitely limped across that river a
few times the worst is dying at the
river you know got your boy you lose so
much there oh sorry the trailer was just
going that was a battle of wills between
us to jce and neither one of us blinked
yeah that's great no III for whatever I
think it still I couldn't hunt
I couldn't hunt for you got a during the
warm months because the game is scarce
in the winter well now I know that now
you gotta kill more than you can carry
back to the wagon yeah yeah no I would
hunt and then it was too heavy and then
the oxen would die I just I never I
could never get the bull help yet I'm
sure you can get on your phone now or
something
I'm sorry we'll get you to Oregon but
then like talk about high anxiety if
you've braved so many dangers and
forwarded so many rivers and then like
it becomes an action game where it's
Nick dodge the rocks what and if you
crash this game over there's no there's
no check there we go back up the chimney
rock no you're screwed you are screwed
how is that not been adapted in like a
Netflix show or somewhere doing it
Buster's right before we started
recording this I read that they're doing
a Funko movie so I'm sure that's gonna
make me bread box myself maybe show me
the [ __ ] out
guys are just gonna win a BD Wong who I
was curious how he managed to kill
himself just with wit with the whole
with core strength alone could I don't
think I could slam my head I'm not gonna
prove it hard enough on any surface to
with my hands tied behind my back
that's the power of the Six Flags guy
yeah that'll do it to you yeah you find
a way life finds a way or death almost
can we talk about deleted stuff right
deleted stuff let's see let's see you
story mother Sandra look mother may i
Rosie moon sight prick rhymes I'm leavin
John Malkovich creep impact would you be
my Gaber M&M a shady slim this boy
strife girl you'll be upriver soon and
I'm sorry got to keep it about fifty row
row row your boat blindly down the
stream blind spot a happening to
electric bullock ooh how many times have
we done an electric something something
enough that one was my and i think yeah
we all have to take it work though it is
the go to sequel name yeah did we not do
we decide not to do Pete Davidson yeah I
thought we've recorded that well we did
record it I guess we just didn't know
Machine Gun Kelly yeah yeah that was a
funny one
yeah my my my Boogaloo was unbreakable
yeah I'm breakable too was making a joke
about them doing calling glass some
break music yeah everybody gets one
spider-man that amazing spider-man 2
Electro's Boogaloo yeah
what's your Boogaloo write in the
comment below so yeah I mean final
thoughts it's like these Netflix movies
they're fine they're good I wouldn't
paid $12 to see him but the fact that I
pay $12 a month means that I'm not mad
at it
it's hard to get mad at something where
there just haven't thrown it up there
and it's like oh this is fair yeah the
bar is pretty low yeah
are you guys gonna watch what's their
new one 10/10 is that what's called with
the the earth is poisoned and the lazy I
get to a spaceship so they put somebody
out I don't even know this is the only
one that's auto-playing when i open
netflix interesting yeah hmm I barely
good Marie Kondo tidying up I keep
trying to make me tidy up
I've been tidying every condo has
changed my life really I have a much
more positive relationship with my
material possessions now thank you very
much time to start folding your clothes
they stand up on their own and I can see
it but it's how you do it cuz now I can
see all my stuff all at once and I feel
more gratitude towards it and I care
about all of it more I've told it that
sparks joy in my life and now I have to
stick to that nice it's a commitment I
steer stuff I'm excited for the like
asylum version of this movie where they
do it where like you can't taste
anything yeah otherwise yeah
because after a quiet place and this one
we're running at a sense as fast the
fields don't touch any of those I'd
watch the fields or even taste that's it
for me what are you thinking Dan mmm
anything else about bird box no I kind
of forgot most of it after I saw it was
a very it was a quick quick meal that's
a very quick meal yeah but I'd rather do
that then we were gonna do the Lego
Batman movie which was that movie is an
honest trailer of Batman yes so you
can't triple-stamp a double-stamp no I
can't honest trailer Lego Batman so
let's do box and you know we're doing
next week something that you've probably
seen again and again hmm
and again yeah so I know this one's kind
of loopy but that's the screen junkies
problem hope you're coming back next
week for another martial arts weapon and
more of three of us
thank you for watching honest trailer
commentaries
[Music]
you